les températures négatives réjouissent
les vignerons et les arboriculteurs
moins de 0°gr au mois de janvier c'est
normal et pourtant c'est presque devenu
exceptionnel un froid qui avait manqué
au producteur de fruits car le gel à
cette période de l'année ne pose pas de
problème puisque les bourgeons ne sont
pas encore ouverts il permet même de
bloquer la végétation et de garantir une
floraison homogène à condition qu'au
qu'in gel ne survienne au printemps
romain
Delville sur les plateaux de vousvrez
roche Corbon et yevgenie taille les
vignes dans le secteur des quart de sang
se battu par les vents jusque fin mars
le froid est un allié qui empêche un
bourgeonnement précoce le froid en ce
moment il est plutôt le bienvenu parce
qu'il faisait quand même très doux et
très humide avant donc le risque c'est
que les bourgeons se mettent à gonfler
tôt et qu'on gèle au printemps c'est
toujours un petit peu ce qu'on craint
donc là le le fait de tailler à poussier
en soi n'apporte pas grand-chose par
rapport à la résistance au gel c'est
plutôt un élément de qualité et de
répartition des v des grappe au moment
des vendanges en arboriculture le
travail de la taille est différent le
principe c'est de supprimer les branches
anciennees pour renouveler par des
nouvelles branches qui ont un an ou deux
donc on va supprimer des branches plus
grosses comme ça récupérer celle-ci où
on retrouve les boutons les futures
fleurs et futures pommes qui sont ici
ici ici Sébastien de la recultive des
pomme à saint-auin- ledépin et les 6
degrés de cet après-midi c'est encore un
peu trop chaud pour l'arboriculteur
non c'est pas assez froid là les
derniers jours il a fait un peu de
température négative donc ça c'est bien
il faudra que ça dure comme ça au moins
un mois faudrait qu'on ait du froid on a
eu beaucoup d'eau courant
décembre voilà donc les réserves sont
pleines tout ce qui est les étend tout
ça c'est plein donc maintenant on
aimerait avoir un temps un peu plus sec
et froid pour pour le repos de de
l'arbre dans les vignes comme dans les
arbres fruitiers le froid de ces
derniers jours est une bonne nouvelle
pour les agricultes
afin que la nature ne se réveille pas
trop vite et que les bourgeons ne soient
pas fragiles en cas de gel au
printemps